well today marks 40 years since the
centers for disease control published
the first report of what would come to
be known as hiv aids
according to the world health
organization the disease has killed 33
million people worldwide
today an estimated 38 million people are
living with hiv
the virus that causes aids and in the
past 20 years
infections and deaths have fallen
dramatically thanks to awareness and new
treatments
but in those earliest days of the
epidemic fear
discrimination and a lack of
understanding of the virus made
containing
and defeating it all the more difficult
published on june 5th 1981 this cdc
report described
a pneumonia-like disease in five
previously healthy
gay men in los angeles while the disease
was a mystery with no name then
the study is regarded as the arrival of
the hiv aids epidemic
dr michael gottlieb published the paper
40 years ago
when your paper was initially published
was there much of a reaction
well people tell me particularly people
in the lgbtq community tell me that they
remember where they were
when they read this publication and they
had
an uncomfortable feeling about what was
going on
but the reaction of the general public
was basically flat
it it really didn't make it onto
anybody's radar
and it didn't make it onto the radar of
most politicians
but uncovering the origin of aids and
how it is spread took
years by then millions of people had
been infected
the disease was first detected in the
gay community and often referred to
inaccurately as gay cancer i remember
those very first patients as well as i
remember patients i saw yesterday
i remember their stories their faces
i remember their occupations i remember
how they dealt
with this undiagnosed illness that had
no
no cause and no name with incredible
strength and understanding and grace it
wasn't until
1985 that president ronald reagan first
publicly addressed aids when he defended
his administration from criticism
that it had inadequately funded aids
research
this is a top priority with us by then
more than 3600 americans
had died from aids that was a very
dark time in our country paul olsen is
chief communications officer for gmhc
an organization founded in 1982 as
gay men's health crisis the first hiv
aids service organization in the world
at that time our government was not
stepping up
and assuming their responsibility for
responding to this crisis because
it was primarily affecting a community
that was
deeply marginalized at the time sensing
a lack of help from the government aids
activists
including a group that disrupted the cbs
evening news in one
instance the story at home is aids and
the television is responsible to cover
that
pushed for change
along with activism cultural flash
points put aids into the public
consciousness
the death of hollywood actor rock hudson
a gloveless princess diana shaking hands
with aids patients
in the uk and magic johnson's
shocking retirement announcement in
which he revealed he was hiv positive
hiv virus that i have attained
i will have to retire from the lakers
and in the mid 90s a medical
breakthrough
the development of anti-retroviral
treatment
that turned hiv aids from a virtual
death sentence
to a manageable disease today more than
two-thirds of those living with hiv
are receiving that treatment but the
epidemic remains in what paul olsen
calls the last mile what are some
misconceptions paul that still exists
today
about hiv aids i think the biggest
misconception is that the epidemic is
over
and we still
are seeing the unacceptably high numbers
of new infections especially in
black and brown and low-income
communities that are
disproportionately affected by other
infectious diseases
where do things stand now since you
first submitted that article to the cdc
there's been a remarkable developments
in both treatment and prevention over
these last 40 years
but today a person aged 25 diagnosed hiv
positive and who's able to
get on medication right away is
projected to have a virtually normal
lifespan
and that is a big big change from what
it was
in 1981. did you think
that the medical community would get to
that point where you would be able
to say that to a patient 40 years after
you submitted that paper
no i didn't the goal of the united
nations aids task force
is to end the epidemic by 2030. they
have what is called the 90 90 90
target they want 90 percent of those
infected with hiv
to know they are infected 90 percent
receiving
antiretroviral treatment and 90
of those who are receiving treatment to
have viral suppression to where they can
no longer
transmit the virus now it's ambitious
but the numbers today
are not far off from those targets but
just listening uh to the doctor there
one of the things that is so
credited with helping to change public
attitudes on this
are those public figures coming out and
doing what they did
and speaking about it in a way that at
the time was considered taboo so
that really does go a long way to
changing people's
mindsets but it changes it changed some
of the prejudice because
those were people that the public knew
that's right 30 years ago
who would have imagined johnson so many
people
like him still alive right at the you
know a top form
it just um it makes you believe
in something greater yeah it just does
progress has been made they didn't even
have a name for it 40 years ago still no
vaccine but the the treatment options
have been just
remarkable a lot of work still to do
this gotta have money though
for some of those treatment options